Lack of health insurance can increase health care costs.
This map shows that other than the U.S. virtually all developed
nations have universal health care that covers everyone.
The Affordable Care Act's major coverage provisions went into effect in
January 2014 and have led to significant coverage gains,
but as of the end of
2016 estimates were that around 30 million Americans were still uninsured.
The Institute of Medicine,
widely referred to as the IOM,
is the health care arm of the National Academy of Science,
which was founded in 1863 under President Lincoln.
According to the IOM the uninsured on average use
less health care than do insured persons and members of fully insured families.
That's lost utilization may be hidden from view,
but it can prove costly in terms of subs with ill health disability and premature death.